okay so over the last 48 hours we have
witnessed the complete
and total disintegration of mibr cs go
after a parade of abysmal results after
months of frankly cringe-worthy twitter
drama
after the conviction and banning of
their coach for cheating
the final nail in the mibr coffin
has been hammered in
[Music]
okay guys before we go any further with
this story i gotta remind you
to subscribe to the score esports
youtube channel if you haven't already
we publish videos pretty much every
single day
and if you don't want to miss one best
thing to do hit the subscribe button
and turn those notifications on do it
now back to mibr
48 hours ago the org officially released
taco
fur and their player manager dead taco
and fur obviously
being two-thirds of that two-time major
winning brazilian core
the next day fallen announced that he
was stepping down from the active roster
saying in a statement posted to his
twitter quote i'm not satisfied with the
recent decision
last weeks have been tough and
challenging and that is why i'm asking
to leave the active roster
will i think on my next steps this time
will be necessary to find my essence and
return the peace i need
to decide my path while i accomplish my
contractual obligations
the only thing i'm sure is this isn't
where the game ends for me
end quote and there it is in just a few
days a group of
legendary players who once ruled the
world of counter-strike
have been kicked off or left mibr
with kng and trk sitting there wondering
what the [ __ ] just happened
now obviously these moves did not come
out of thin air
but where do you even start when you
look at the history of mibr that led to
this point
i mean 2020 has been a disaster for the
organization
on and off the server but first i think
we have to remind ourselves
just how big of a deal this team was
when they originally launched
two years ago made in brazil was a
legendary brazilian
cs brand brought back from the dead by
north american esports organization
immortals and they signed the then sk
gaming roster including the core the
major winning core
of fur fallen and coldzera all players
at that time still considered very
skilled
and very dangerous
they just had so much hype going and it
really felt like a major coup not only
for immortals but for brazilian cs
but if you look back on it all now the
amount of notable first place finishes
they had in those two years
you can basically count on one hand now
granted 2018 did have some bright spots
and so did the beginning of 2019
but the second half of that year things
start to slow downward
especially when you consider they failed
to make top eight at a major
for the first time since some of these
guys were on keyed stars
in 2015 and in 2020 that slope goes full
vertical
now there were a few glimmers of hope at
the beginning of the year and i stress
glimmers but just when you think things
might be starting to look up for the
team
the [ __ ] show summer of mibr begins
first comes the furia drama back on june
16th of this year
mibr and furia are tied 12-12 on inferno
during the blast premiere spring fallen
lags out of the server
and mibr get extremely pissy
about furia agreeing or not agreeing
to replay the round they take to social
media
and cause a toxic shitstorm calling fury
as [ __ ]
and basically insinuating that they only
agreed to restart the round because of
social media pressure now all of that
sounds
silly stupid kind of funny at times and
it is
but you have to remember that we're
dealing with a brazilian cs fan base
that is very passionate about their
teams their players and their esports
and that means that things can get out
of hand
really fast analyst chad burchill
appearing on the hltv confirmed podcast
put the seriousness of this situation in
context pretty well
those kids could you imagine like how
[ __ ] horrible
that must feel to be in the middle of a
game right
and have that turned on you right these
people that you once [ __ ]
respected the [ __ ] out of turning on you
in the middle of a game that you your
[ __ ] job
right and then after the aftermath of
all of this like the tweets that came
out like
fur calling them [ __ ] i don't think he's
calling them [ __ ] players i think what
he was trying to insinuate was was there
was [ __ ] people for not the the take i
took from
the mrbr count was they didn't think
that furious were being men
and that they were being fair by fair
play but this is a this is a job with
hundreds of thousands of dollars on the
line and they're trying to be
professional
about this right leave it up to the
admins leave it up to your coach
like this shouldn't be a conversation of
hey let's like of course there should
have been a restart of course there
should have been but this is in the
middle of the game
and these kids i could see how
frustrated they were after it they were
all losing it
they were all losing after they didn't
want to be in the server anymore right
they didn't want to be there playing
anymore
and it it really it really [ __ ] got
to me man because i
i don't understand like how they can do
that and
and then not apologize just a week later
things got even worse after a game
against chaos esports
and if you're interested in diving
deeper onto this controversy
well we made an entire video on it click
right above my head to check that out
but the tl dr here is that two
individuals on chaos esports club were
accused of cheating
and members of the cs go community at
large including
fallen dog piled on those accusations
and that implicitly weaponized toxic
elements of the brazilian cs fan base
hundreds and hundreds of abusive
messages including death threats
were blasted at members of chaos esports
club
including a 16 year old player named
leaf
it was really [ __ ] sad oh and that
happened at cs summit an event that mibr
completely bombed out of
coming last in their group and failing
to even make it to the bracket stage
now between cs summit and esl one
cologne the team moved to europe for the
2020
online version of cologne and if you
thought mibr's results were
disappointing before
let me take you on a bit of a journey
here it starts with mibr getting blasted
out of the water by g2 esports losing
16-2
and 16-4 in an o2 match at columbia
dominance this is his map and this is
g2's half
11-4 mibr looking like a shadow of their
former selves
after which more drama erupted on
twitter between chaos esports club and
mibr fans
then mibr get booted out of cologne by
faze clan
after which they start taking l's from
teams like
forza copenhagen flames mad lines with
no bubsky gambit youngsters
plus a bunch of teams that frankly
you've never even heard of
like vizla krakov pact and galaxy racer
and these
results are quite simply shocking when
you consider the caliber of talent that
mibr had on their roster
some of these players have achieved
legendary status
they have major trophies on their
mantels
trophies plural now if you're asking
yourself at this point how things could
get any worse
how about mibr coach and manager dead
being among those
revealed to have cheated using a
coaching spectating bug
resulting in a six-month ban from
esl by the way we do have a whole video
on that subject so if you're interested
in diving deeper
into the cs go coaching scandal go ahead
and check that out fast forward to just
a few days ago
and all of that is academic now as for
what's going to happen to the remaining
players
while kng took to twitter to voice his
dissatisfaction
with mibr's decision to kick taco fur
and dead
by saying on twitter quote i do not
agree with the changes
in the team unfortunately since i joined
here it is changing lines all the time
what in my view does not help the
development of the team
end quote trk also retweeted that so
read into that as you will
when it comes to the now departed core
of fur fallen and taco
only time will tell but you want to
believe that they're not a fully spent
force yet
you want to believe that guys who have
more major trophies than
nico simple and guardian can still hang
competitively
maybe not to the degree they did in
their glory days but after the last four
months of disappointment on
and off the server honestly anything
would be an improvement
two-thirds of that
how good things well guys end of the
video
coming at you from my new house yes
that's right
i've been on vacation for three weeks
i've been away from the score for three
weeks
big reason for that is me and the missus
bought a home
i'm in it right now in a temporary
shooting space i've actually got a whole
new one built out upstairs it's just not
quite ready for prime time yet
but uh it's been a crazy three weeks man